hay un nuevo giro en la estrategia
militar rusa en Ucrania el Ministerio de
defensa publicado un comunicado donde
aseguran que está finalizada esta
primera fase de lo que ellos denominan
la operación militar y que se van a
centrar en el don vass y en otras
ciudades sobre el terreno viene a
confirmar lo que estamos viendo los
últimos días las tropas rusas no han
podido llegar aquí Ucrania está
retomando posiciones en esa zona norte
de la capital y se han centrado más en
los ataques en el este y en el sur para
crear ese corredor que les lleve
directamente al mar Negro en esa fase
Mario Paul va a ser clave es la ciudad
más bombardeada martirizada está
destrozada las últimas informaciones
apuntan a que el ejército ruso está allá
en el centro de esa ciudad de cumplirse
la hoja de ruta que insinúa ese
comunicado estaríamos ante una nueva
fase en esta guerra que pasaría por
ampliar territorios en el don Bass dejar
partido este país más allá del Don Bass
pero se descartaría un escenario de
guerra Total como en el que estamos
viviendo desde hace más de un mes